forces
awesome okay so for our last uh top of
the day we have mark selfies
okay uh thanks everyone for coming and
thanks to the organizers for the
invitation the nice workshop
so i'll tell you about tight i'll grin
the thresholds for optimizing mean field
spinglass hamiltonians and this is
joined with bryce who just spoke
okay so
what i'll do today is as follows i'll
set up the problem tell you what these
functions we're trying to optimize are
then i'll fill you in on various
background material i'll tell you about
our new result which is a tight
characterization of the best value you
can achieve with a with a certain class
of efficient algorithms
and then i'll tell you about some of the
key ideas involving ultra metricity and
a branching version of the overlap gap
property
okay
so
here's the model in one equation we're
going to construct a random function h n
from r n to r it's going to be a random
polynomial of degree capital k
and the coefficients will basically be
iid standard gaussians
uh it's just that there's some scaling
so there's some scaling which is a power
of n which just ensures that every
degree contributes on the same order and
there's some constants gamma which are
just
differing depending on the degree
an equivalent description is that we can
put all these gamma constants together
into a one-variable polynomial c and
then hn is just a centered gaussian
process with covariance given by taking
a normalized inner product and applying
c so c is kind of a nice way to
encapsulate all of these coefficients
into one nice object
we're going to look at two input sets
today and kind of treat them in parallel
there's the easing case where we look at
inputs on the cube and there's a
spherical case where we look at inputs
on the sphere
okay
let me tell you a little bit about the
motivations in history so
the first model like this is i think the
sk model which is a quadratic
hamiltonian
it was introduced to studying various
types of
magnetic alloys
and what happens here is that the
magnetic interaction between particles
is kind of depending in a complicated
way on the distance so we just think of
it as an easing model with random
couplings
okay and then if we want to make our
lives a little bit easier we forget that
we're in a 3d space and we just take a
mean field version of the problem so we
make all of the um the couplings iid
from this point taking higher degree
extensions and spherical inputs are
mathematically natural just to give
ourselves kind of a bigger sandbox
these models also arise in various other
ways you can reach them as high degree
limits of things like max cut and max
set
um they're also just a rich sorts of
random non-convex functions and they're
related to some neural network models
okay um now probably the most celebrated
fact about these mean-filled spin
glasses is the prezi formula which is um
approved by hologram and there are
various other uh results that i've
listed here
um in a nutshell uh what the result says
is that in both the cube and the
spherical case
um if you look at the maximum value of
this hamiltonian appropriately
normalized and in the large end limit uh
it'll have some limiting value i'll call
this opt
and this limiting value is given by some
sort of explicit minimization problem
over the space of increasing functions
on the interval zero one
so there's a different prezi functional
in the easing and the spherical case and
i won't actually write it down but
there's some minimization problem over
increasing functions
um so the main question i'm going to try
to address today is what can we do with
efficient algorithms can we
come up with efficient algorithms to
reach this optimal value and if not what
kind of value can we reach efficiently
does this problem make sense
probably many of us have heard a couple
talks about this type of thing before
okay
so um let me quickly say something about
the landscape so if we have a function
that's close to convex maybe we can just
do gradient descent but this isn't
really what happens
so these functions if you look at them
on the sphere they can have um a huge
number of uh near-optimal
local maxima which sounds like maybe
it's good but they have even more
places we get stuck that aren't so good
so we probably can't just use gradient
descent um i also want to mention that
if you have a worst case problem
instance like this you can't even get a
constant approximation factor
so we're going to need to use the
randomness and we probably can't use
gradient descent
um but it turns out that as far as
computational complexity goes we don't
have to look too much further than
gradient descent
um
and
so there have been several recent papers
on this starting with cbog and then
andrea figured out how to do it for the
cube
and in a nutshell the result is that we
can achieve
a
smaller value called alg which is given
by the same minimization problem but
over
a larger set of functions so previously
for the true maximum value we have to
minimize over all increasing functions
but this algorithmic value is
given by minimizing over like kind of
all functions so they don't have to be
increasing anymore
these in case
we have to assume that a minimizer to
this variational problem exists
okay approximate message passing is
really efficient it only uses a constant
number of gradient queries um and it's
you know great for a lot of statistical
problems as we've heard about
um a very very brief summary of this
type of algorithm is that
there's a stochastic differential
equation related to this um
crazy formula and we're going to
simulate an associated stochastic
differential equation um using amp
and
we actually showed that if you use an
amp algorithm with this very specific
setup you cannot do better than this out
value
roughly speaking
when algae equals up this corresponds to
a no overlapped gap
on the other hand when there is an
overlap gap which actually
is essentially just on the complement of
when amp
works
you can show that no sufficiently stable
algorithm can achieve up
these results hold
basically in general except that you
need to assume these um odd coefficients
are
zero so there's no odd degree terms
except maybe the linear term
okay
so
stable algorithms uh include a lot of
things
they include constant number of gradient
descender amp iterations language
dynamics slow degree polynomials many
things
and
the proof is based on this overlapped up
property that bryce just talked about
it's a family of topological hardness
criteria there have been many papers on
this kind of thing
um let me show you another sort of
cartoon of the overlapped gap property
so we're going to consider an
interpolation path in this case we're
just going to take two independent
hamiltonians hn0 and hn1 and we're going
to interpolate between them so that
everyone along this path has the same
marginal
and
the idea here is that morally the
algorithm gives us a continuous path and
there's some intermediate distance qogp
that we have to cross by continuity
and
the overlap.property lets us say that
if we have two points at this
intermediate distance q or gp then they
can't both be near optimal
and
that's how you can show that stable
algorithms can't reach opt
so the new result i want to tell you
about today is a
[Music]
kind of similar statement except we can
get all the way down to alg
so we can show that no algorithm
satisfying a certain overlap
concentration property is able to get
any better than alg
this is again for even models and um it
doesn't include quite all of the
algorithms uh that gamarnik draganov and
one were able to rule out but it
includes amp and gradient descent and
things that look like that
um moreover it holds in a strong sense
so for all of these algorithms we can
handle we can actually rule out anything
better than an exponentially small and n
probability of getting better than alg
and to give you some idea this is the
same up to the constant in the exponent
as just ignoring the input entirely and
just guessing a random point
the proof is going to rely on a new
branching version of the
overlap.property
and
right at the end i'll as i'll try to
explain a little bit more um we can show
that in spherical models uh we kind of
actually need to use this uh branching
over laptop property and any kind of
simple ogp is not able to get all the
way down to alg
so the core idea behind
what we do is based around ultra
metricity so let me remind you what an
ultrametric space is
an ultrametric is a stronger
type of metric space that has this phi
that satisfy this ultrametric triangle
inequality
another way to think of it is that it's
a hierarchical clustering or
you can just take a tree and look at the
corresponding graph metric on the leaves
um and it's known with some technical
caveats that i won't get into that if
you look at the positive temperature
version of this problem so you look at
the gibbs measure proportional to e to
the beta h
then it's sort of supported on an
ultrametric space so this is some deep
stuff that has guided the study of these
models since the beginning and it's um
you know it kind of suggests that ultra
metricity should should be related to
these models
even for algorithms movie
and here's a way that algorithms uh for
these models are related to
ultrametricity
you can you can build uh
more outputs than just one with these
algorithms
so the the amp algorithms um
for this problem roughly speaking
explore um by taking many small steps
because they're simulating a stochastic
differential equation
and
you can define a branching version of it
that
you know kind of re-randomizes things a
couple times and creates a bunch of
different outputs
if you do this uh you can you can
construct a bunch of outputs and in fact
for any fixed size ultrametric space x
um
you can you can output a bunch of points
whose ultra whose metric structure is
the same as x
and each of them attain the same
energy value out
so if we can do this with algorithms
then this suggests maybe we can use a
really strong version of the overlap gap
property that kind of
matches this
ability
so in the classic ogp we're rolling out
pairs of solutions
in something i'll just call a one layer
ogp we can roll out
tuples of more than two uh points where
all the distances are about the same
um there's also something you might call
a ladder ogp with some kind of
multi-distance thing like what bryce was
talking about
in a branching ogp we're going to be
rolling out configurations that
approximate an arbitrarily complicated
ultrametric space i suggest that we call
it deep or gp
[Music]
is also pronounced
[Laughter]
a very complicated ultrametric space is
nothing mysterious it's just a tree
that's kind of branching constantly at
all levels so it's um you know a
tree that branches maybe every depth
delta or something
but as you can see it's going to be more
complicated than these um these other
types of configurations
okay so the first question that may come
to mind is like why would how would we
get to hardness from here so
um
in versions of the ogp that are like
these um previous
uh setups uh you can imagine some
continuous path where you stop at the
right points like what um bryce was
explaining in his talk uh and and you if
you stop at the right points you get a
configuration like this
um
so we're gonna do something different
and it's uh why we need this notion of
overlap concentration so we're going to
say an algorithm is overlap concentrated
if the following occurs so we fix t
and we take two
inputs that are kind of correlated by an
amount t
along this interpolation path so so
we're taking uh you know gaussian
coefficients for our random polynomial
but they're correlated on the two
problem instances
and the algorithm is going to be overlap
concentrated if the distance between the
outputs tightly concentrates around some
function of t and this concentration
quality should be uniform over the value
of t
so what does the picture look like it
looks like we look at several different
interpolation paths um i'll just say
from the same point
and
um previously we said that by continuity
they have to reach this this mode
somewhere and overlap concentration is
going to say that they they reach the
mode at the same time so so at the same
value of t they're reaching this um this
mode
this
property is a bit stronger than
stability but if the algorithm has some
suitable type of lipschitz dependence on
hn then it holds automatically by just
concentration of matter and
this is how you can show that things
like gradient descent and amp satisfy
this property
but we don't know how to show it for
loaded polynomials we're not sure if
it's true even with some extra types of
nice assumptions
okay
so what can we do with an overlap
concentrated algorithm so the first step
is that we're going to take some
arbitrary ultrametric space x
and we're going to create some
correlated hamiltonians
one for each point in x
they're going to be correlated in such a
way so that when i have two points x1
and x2 that are close
according to this ultrametric then these
hamiltonians will be more correlated
together so this is this you can
generate them by taking like a brownian
motions on a tree to generate the
gaussians
and
overlap concentration is going to say
that if i apply my algorithm
then all of the distances will transform
deterministically and this means that
i'll get a new ultrametric space
just by applying this transformation
function chi to every distance
um chi you can show is continuous uh so
that means that we can get any
ultrametric we want on the right hand
side as a structure of
outputs for the algorithm
okay so what this means is that if we
have an overlap concentrated algorithm
that achieves a value alg plus epsilon
then
um by choosing x on the left-hand side
appropriately we can get a configuration
of
algorithmic output sigma that
approximate whatever ultrametric we want
and
each of these points has a large value
of hn
is this okay
great
so let me um just say a little bit about
how
we can rule out such a configuration and
then i'll be finished
um so we're going to take this forbidden
structure chi of x to be a kre tree that
branches at every multiple of delta so
kind of a continuously branching random
tree
in fact you know these are sort of
universal for finite ultrametrics so if
i have any finite ultrametric with an
appropriate diameter bound
i can approximately embed it into an
appropriately fine-grained tree like
this
so we're using the full strength of the
ultra matrices
okay
there's a upper bound proof for the
prezi formula based on some
interpolation some fancy royal cascades
and somehow it generalizes to richer
settings like this one
and what we can do is we can uniformly
over all configurations with this type
of metric structure
we can control the average value of hn
over these
these
points
um so it's just like bounding the
maximum value but but overall
configurations with this structure and
we just we just average the energy over
the point set
capital x is fixed yeah yeah we fixed
the ultrametric structure
yeah
we take n to infinity
um so just like in the
classical prezi formula somehow if i
give you any increasing function
it can be plugged into this type of
upper bound scheme and you get an upper
bound at the end
so you can express this as a
multi-dimensional generalization of
these prezi functionals
okay and it turns out that
if you work at it you can transform this
multi-dimensional uh prezi functional uh
back into some stuff in terms of
one-dimensional pre-z functional so
we're we're back in like
you know
we've found this uh ordinary prezi
functional again but um
the
the
increasing function we started with
actually transforms we don't get the
same uh
increasing function at the end we get a
something that's no longer increasing
so this is how we're able to get to
non-monotone functions um
which went into defining helg
i mean so so
i think it should be a taller grounds
work um
what was the motivation for different
looking at different texts different
habitonians that
are the hxl different from your
foreigners oh um oh yeah okay so for
that i might not be in polygons work um
like i guess it's called like vector
spin glasses i think that should
that keyword should include it
somehow it's like you know if the same
proof technique works maybe someone will
work out how it works i'm not sure
exactly what the first place to consider
slightly different
i think the vector
so you read the calculation for
different topics just to understand it
yeah yeah but just the upper bound right
yeah just the upper bound yeah but yeah
so you also have to redo everything
carefully because um
like you can't assume chi is like
independent of n you can't assume kai is
a fixed function it can depend on n it's
modulus of continuity can blow up with n
so you have to kind of do everything
pretty explicitly
are there questions about this
okay i'll just finish up so so somehow
this increasing function that we can
plug in to get a bound uh turns into a
no longer increasing function uh let me
show you what actually happens uh so
it's very similar to the original
function the ratio is piecewise constant
but basically the the transformed
function you get out that you plug into
the ordinary pre-z functional
shrinks at every time this tree branches
so it shrinks at every multiple of delta
because we looked at an ultrametric tree
that branches at every multiple of delta
and
um
it's
it's now just a matter of observing that
if i if i have a function that's like
increasing but i can decrease it every
multiple of delta then i can i can take
any
reasonable function i want and build an
approximation to it um just by
decreasing it kind of the right amount
every time
um so that's that's how you get an upper
bound of plus epsilon you approximate an
arbitrary
non-increasing function
so there's no need to assume that a
minimizer exists here you just you just
approximate anything
if we compare this to what happens with
the classic ogp forbidden structure you
have a tree that only branches once
what this means is you get a function at
the end that only can decrease once so
you break out of like increasing
function land which is why you can
get below opt but you can't approximate
a general function with a function that
can only decrease once
this limitation is kind of fundamental
what we can show is that at least in a
spherical model
if you want to rule out alg plus epsilon
using a forbidden ultrametric tree
then these trees have to contain full
binary sub trees of size that diverges
as you send epsilon to zero
so you can take an ultrametric structure
that's really large but if this
if the largest binary subtree largest
full binary sub tree in it has bounded
size this is some you know notion of
parametrizing the complexity then you
won't be able to reach all the way down
to elk
okay and if you have a full binary tree
of unbounded size you basically have
this branching construction so that's
that's the sense in which i mean that
this is uh necessary
okay uh let me just conclude now um we
looked at the problem of optimizing a
mean field spin glass hamiltonian
um and we showed that this alg value is
the best asymptotic value achievable by
a certain class of
algorithms that we're calling overlap
concentration
these algorithms include a constant
number of iterations of gradient descent
in amp and the proof uses a branching
version of the overlapped gap property
based on general ultrametric trees which
is in some sense necessary
a natural open direction i'm very
excited about is to
see if this kind of
branching ogp can identify the exact
algorithmic threshold for more general
problems because this connection seems
like it could just
be very
general
thanks let me know if you have any more
questions
yeah sam how much hope is there to bring
other algorithms into the fold of what
would be ruled out by this kind of uh
this kind of conservation op um
yeah that's a very good question but
that's also a great direction so so yeah
i'm not sure like
if it's possible to show that
like low degree polynomials satisfy this
property maybe if you make another nice
assumption or two or if if like
this proof technique can be relaxed a
little bit so that you don't need
overlap concentration exactly
um
yeah i'm i'm not sure there are also
just algorithms where it's like like if
you look at something like global
dynamics it seems like maybe it's
overlap concentrated but it's not easy
to show that it is so that's also
something that could be done yeah
um yeah so uh
so that's coming from much earlier
towards the beginning
if you run this amp together with
branching you reach a bunch of points
those points the metric structure on
them approximates and sometimes the
ultrametric tree
um so then also it seems in some sense
to approximate the gibbs measure itself
and yet sampling from the gibbs measure
at low temperature for the sk model
should be hard right so there is
something broken in that
that sounds so i think like what you can
think happens is like you have a big uh
ultrametric tree rate
um
and the measure is going to like
okay so like these are all the points
that have value off minus epsilon
okay there's a lot of them
but if you look at the gibbs measure
these small energy differences will will
matter enough so that the support is
really on a pretty small amount of
distribution
i think that's kind of the
cartoon i have in my head
so maybe so you kind of guess you know
some kind of
it's like the sense in which something
is a good
approximation of the git snatcher or not
like to be really a good approximation
would have to have a lot of points like
combine granularity
yeah
yeah this is all just like a first order
approximations are also in the linear
scale
so
8.